Ariana Grande wow
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es einen Spaghetti Auflauf
Pizza Style ihr könnt diesen Spaghetti
auch noch gerne machen wenn ihr zum
Beispiel ein paar Nudeln übrig habt oder
ihr kocht gleich so wie ich einfach
Nudeln ab wo habe ich mich richtig
erschreckt mache hinten kurz
durchgedreht
und schmeißt Kartons um aber ist okay
jedenfalls ist es heute Pizza Style und
da dürft ihr natürlich selber
entscheiden was reinkommt ihr könnt
natürlich Resteverwertung machen Fleisch
Gemüse Käse alles mit reinpacken oder
eben sogar gezielt dafür einkaufen und
sagen ihr macht Spaghetti Auflauf Pizza
tonus-style oder welche Pizza ihr auch
immer gerne mögt ich habe jetzt hier
schon eine Packung Nudeln ich habe jetzt
hier Spaghetti einfach in heißen
Salzwasser also kochendem Salzwasser
aufgekocht das ganze aber nicht ganz
durchgegart denn ich will dass sie
später im Ofen noch Biss haben wenn er
natürlich fertig gekarte Spaghetti übrig
habt dann macht das aber auch nichts
jetzt zeige ich euch noch was ich
außerdem an Zutaten brauche dafür nehmt
ihr 800 g stückelte Tomaten aus der Dose
mit Knoblauchzehe eine Paprika hier habe
ich etwas Käse wie Gouda und Mozzarella
Salz und Pfeffer Tomatenmark Oregano
Mais Sucuk und Olivenöl
dann habe ich hier eine Ofenform meine
Spaghetti man sieht auch hier ganz
deutlich dass der noch nicht ganz gar
sind
die gebe ich hier rein aber sie sind
schon flexibel genug dass sie sich gut
verteilen
da gebe ich jetzt schon mal ein bisschen
Olivenöl drauf damit Sie gleich nicht
kleben
der Ofen ist jetzt auch vorgeheizt geht
jetzt auch echt recht schnell ist auch
was was meine Kids bestimmt sehr mögen
und der Murat
dann den Nudeln so ein bisschen
verteilen
stelle ich kurz zur Seite und kann schon
mal die Tomatensoße vorbereiten dafür
nehme ich jetzt die Tomaten
dann die Knoblauchzehe rein
Salz und Pfeffer
ich koche gerade
Spaghetti Pizza style
und
ja lecker ich glaube Ella wird jetzt
einfach die Zutaten schon roh essen kann
das sein
Mais
ihr könnt auch Peperoni reinmachen
Oliven ich habe jetzt nur Peperoni raus
weil ich dachte mir so ihr mögt bestimmt
diese Zutaten oder Sucuk Mozzarella
Paprika Tomatenmark Mais okay
ich gebe jetzt hier zur Tomatensoße auch
das Tomatenmark dazu
und Oregano
[Musik]
die Tomatensoße ist bereit
und die Sucuk Scheiben habe ich ja schon
meistens auch nicht verarbeitet werden
die Paprika wird noch geschnitten und
der Käse gerieben
Ela was sind denn deine lieblings Pizza
Belege was hast denn du gerne auf der
Pizza
Thunfisch hätten wir jetzt auch machen
können passt auch
und ihr könnt ja auch gerne mal
schreiben was eure lieblings Pizza ist
und du mit ihr denn Auflauf machen
würdet
[Musik]
und dann kommt jetzt eigentlich alles
zusammen in die Form also ich würde
jetzt erstmal die Tomatensoße darüber
gießen und die Nudeln auch so ein
bisschen damit vermengen
[Musik]
die Zutaten rein natürlich könnt ihr
auch einfach alles miteinander
vermischen aber ich finde das muss
natürlich später auch ein bisschen Pizza
also schon auch schön belegen aber
dazwischen auch ein bisschen Käse
reinpacken ja alles schön verteilen
kaputt
[Musik]
perfekt so sieht super aus jetzt kommt
schon direkt in den vorgeheizten
Backofen bei 200 Grad ober Unterhitze
wird schon gebacken probiert
seid ihr auch fleißig am Kochen und
Backen
und naschen und essen
ich auch
aber momentan bin ich auch gerade am
hart trainieren denn ich bin ja bei
Let's Dance dabei und ich komme nur
weiter wenn ihr für mich anruft das
heißt backt euch gerne was schönes aber
Freitag Abend da seid ihr bitte live
dabei bei RTL und ruft für mich an
verletzte denn ich will auf jeden Fall
weiterkommen
ich gehe lieber wieder tanzen
[Musik]
jetzt ist es fertig es ist vollbracht
und wir haben Hunger wir haben richtig
Hunger können Sie mir probieren heute
[Applaus]
ich liebe schon jetzt den Part mit Käse
ich drehe mich lieber weg
[Musik]
hast natürlich gleich wieder gemerkt du
oh
mein Gott sei einfach so eine Mischung
aus Spaghetti und Pizza Hammer nicht so
weich also diesen perfekt gegart
deswegen empfehle ich euch schon die im
Topf nicht so lange Garn zu lassen
sondern gerade so dass sie eben schön
geschmeidig sind und da hat man so ein
paar knusprige Stellen obendrauf diese
Käse stellen also ich muss sagen das ist
glaube ich eins meiner neuen
Lieblingsrezepte was sagst du
oder du bist doch bei uns die Pasta
Queen Samira kocht immer Nudeln alle
möglichen Nudelgerichte
auch für die ganze Familie
boah das wirklich der Hammer und ich
glaube selbst Murat würde das Rezept
feiern denn es ist Sucuk vorhanden und
ihr könnt jetzt gerne eure
euren Spaghetti Auflauf auf Pizza Art
zubereiten und mir gerne sagen was ihr
an Zutaten mit rein gibt manchmal bin
ich echt überfragt was ich auf eine
Pizza drauf machen weil ich finde so
eine klassische Pizza mit Sucuk oder
Salami ist schon hammer aber ich gebe
auch Thunfisch Pizza ich gebe auch
Thunfisch Pizza mit roten Zwiebeln ich
liebe aber auch eine Ananas Pizza und
manchmal auch nur eine Pizza also
schreibt mir gerne mal eure Ideen und
Inspirationen denn dann kann ich mich
auch wieder inspirieren lassen und
vielleicht könnten wir noch einen
spaghetti-auflauf 2.0 machen
mit einer weißen cremigen Käsesoße
wir haben alle Hunger wir essen jetzt
also guten Appetit euch und uns im Team
und bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]
bringen wird
schon hinter der Kamera
[Musik]